[Musique]
bonsoir à tous des résultats des 20h des
directs partout chez vous vous avez bien
fait de choisir France 3 pour cette
soirée spéciale élection régionale il
est 19h ça y est le dépouillement est en
cours un peu partout bonsoir ha bonsoir
Arnaud bonsoir à tous pour ne rien rater
de ce second tour encore très indéciis
nos équipes sillonne la Bourgogne et la
franche compté nous serons en direct
depuis différents QG de campagne nous
aurons également des invités en duplexe
mais aussi avec nous sur ce plateau et
puis également avec nous en studio nos
deux journalistes politiques Jérémy
chevreuil et pour commenter également
toute cette soirée Éric SIO Elsa Besin
est aussi avec nous Elsa qui va
commenter tout ce qui se dit et tout ce
qui se fait sur les réseaux sociaux
premier chiffre à retenir de cette
journée ce de la participation les seuls
que nous sommes autorisés à vous donner
avant 20h estimation à 17h en Bourgogne
franchecté la participation sélévraé à
52,8 % contre 50,5 au niveau national
oui c'est une participation en forte
hausse par rapport au premier tour
environ 10 points de plus et plus 5
points par rapport à 2010 on peut noter
à 17h pour la participation que la
Bourgogne a un peu plus voté que la
franche compté la Bourgogne
53,6 % de participation 51 7 pour la
franche comptée alors prenons l'exemple
d'une ville où l'abstention était très
forte la semaine dernière Macon la
préfecture de la sonelloire où 61 % des
électeurs ne s'étaient pas déplacés
attitude difficile à comprendre pour
ceux qui ne ratent aucun scrutin alors
la mobilisation était elle plus forte
aujourd'hui reportage de Damien
Boutillet avec Caroline l duuc à Macon
pour le premier tour des élections
régional la ville était bien loin de
décrocher la palme du civisme car ici on
a frôlé les 61 % d'abstention j'ai du
mal mais j'en connais plein et même dans
mes enfants je suis un peu gêné je
trouve ça
désolant c'est mon opinion mais je
trouve les gens se sont battus pour
qu'on ait le droit de voter on fait au
moins l'effort d'y aller c'est quand
même pas tous les dimanches c'est
essentiel on a on a cette possibilité là
pour pour pour s'exprimer mais depuis ce
matin on sent plus qu'un frémissement
démocratique c'est un sursaut
républicain les électeurs viennent voter
ça vote nettement plus que dimanche
dernier on est
oui on a fait le double à peu près de
votant par rapport à dimanche dernier on
est sur des chiffres déjà d' a d' y a
plus de 5 ans au dernière régionale donc
on est optimiste ainsi les
abstentionnistes de dimanche dernier
retrouvent le chemin des bureaux de vote
et ceux que nous avons croisé acceptent
de nous expliquer pourquoi ils se sont
abstenus le premier je suis désolé parce
que je suis arrivée avec de minutes de
retard donc je suis venu mais donc donc
je je répare mes erreurs après non j'ai
pas voté au premier tour parce que
j'étais absent et aujourd'hui ceux qui
n'ont pas pu venir ont anticipé leur
vote grâce aux procurations la semaine
dernière on en avait 5 et cette semaine
on en a 15 mais sur les 15 comme on a
fait le matin on a déjà vu il y a des
gens qui ont fait des procurations mais
qui ont déjà voté la semaine dernière
aucun doute donc la participation est
supérieure à dimanche dernier dans
certains bureaux de vote Maconnais mais
pour avoir des chiffres précis et
définitifs il faut attendre les
résultats du
tin direction le Pays de Montbéliard à
présent dans le dou ce territoire a
placé la semaine dernière le Front
national largement en tête avec presque
48 % des suffrages comme à socho oui
dans cette ville ouvrière tenue par une
mairie de gauche Frédéric Buridon et
Jean-Luc gantnerer sont allés à la
rencontre des Sochaliens dans les
bureaux de vote ce
matin socho 5000 habitants au premier
tour Sophie Montelle candidate Front
national est arrivé en tête ce matin dès
l'ouverture des bureaux de vote à 8h il
y avait déjà du monde je suis en plein
déménagement donc avant de commencer le
déménagement j'ai dit je vais faire le
devoir citoyen quoi d'accord voilà vous
étiez venu la semaine dernière oui
j'étais déjà venu la semaine dernière et
à chaque vote je viens quoi alors vous
monsieur vous étiez venu déjà au premier
tour non moi je ne suis pas venu au
premier tour j'étais hospitalisé
d'accord non pas de chance sinon je s
venu et puis là c'est important de ah
bah c'est très important là de rattraper
au moins au fil de la journée les
isoloirs n'ont pas été
une progression par rapport au premier
tour on a un petit peu plus de
participation que la semaine dernière
euh disons qu'on est aux alentours pour
l'instant de 40 45
% voilà il a un peu plus de mobilisation
que la semaine dernière plus de votes
par procuration comment ça s'est passé
un peu plus oui environ 50 % de plus que
ce qu'on avait la semaine dernière à la
sortie du bureau de vote dans cette
ville ouvrière qui connaît un fort taux
de chômage le bulletin de vote dans
l'urne tout un symbole on est dans un
moment assez on va
dire critique de notre pays où il faut
commencer à choisir et où il faut
commencer à à montrer ce qu'on veut
c'est très important parce que je pense
qu'il faut exprimer les gens ont un RAL
B ils en ont un r B il faut dire ce
qu'il est les gens en ont marre alors
donc moi je suis contre l'abstention il
faut que les gens all V
on a le Dr on a on a eu le droit de
voter les femmes c'est un devoir Soo
comme beaucoup d'autres villes attend de
connaître le verdict des urnes ce soir
et je vous propose de nous rendre à
présent dans le Jura lon le Sonier nous
attend Vanessa hson Vanessa 19h6 où en
sommes-nous dans le dépouillement de ce
deè
tour écoutez je me trouve dans l'un des
h bureaux de vote de l leier depuis plus
d'une heure les scrutateur dépouill dans
une ambiance appliquée les quelques
bulletins qui ont été déposés ici depuis
ce matin alors dans le Jura à 17h le
taux de participation s'élevé à
52,40 % des suffrages c'est 10 points de
plus par rapport au premier tour alors
ce reg regard de voie va-t-il profiter à
la droite ou à la gauche en tout cas ici
alon le Sonier terire dirigé par la
droite c'est la socialiste Margit Duffet
qui est arrivé en tête au premier tour
mais dans le Jura c'est Sophie Montel
qui est arrivée premier avec 30 % des
suffrages suivis de François sauvad et
Margit Duffet au coude à coude avec 23 %
des suffrages vous l'aurez compris rien
n'est joué il réponse ce soir à 20h
merci Vanessa premier résultat
effectivement des 20h estimation à 20h15
pour la Bourgogne franchecé trois
bureaux de votes ont reçu la visite
d'électeur un peu particulier oui les
trois têtes de liste de ce second tour
sont bien évidemment allés voter
aujourd'hui Marie guit Duffet Sophie
Montel et François sauvadon ont fait
leurs devoirs citoyen des images
commentées par ellisabeth braconnier
elle a été la première à voter pour ce
second tour Marie GUID Duffet est
arrivée au bureau 502 de Bregille
village à 9h40 accompagné de son mari
elle a également voter pour sa fille qui
lui avait confié une procuration mais ne
s'est pas attardé pressé de rejoindre
les siens pour une randonnée en forêt
j'essaie de trouver du calme intérieur
parce que effectivement c'est c'est
compliqué la pression est très forte
mais en cette dernière semaine nous
avons fait le maximum donc maintenant
c'est aux électeurs de trancher en
Bourgogne le chef de fil de la coalition
de l'UDI et des républicains a voté à
11h15 à la mairie de vitau avec sa femme
et deux de ses filles François Sauvadet
devait ensuite rejoindre son équipe au
siège du conseil départemental de Côte
d'Or dans l'après-midi juste pour savoir
quand même votre état d'esprit quand
même qu'est-ce que voulez que je vous
dise aujourd'hui à ce stade les gens
sont est en train de voter voilà donc
vous nêtes pas attendu bon j'attends le
résultat comme tout le monde voil des
trois candidat encore en LCE Sophie
Montel a été la dernière à voter c'était
à midi pile à Saint-Vite avant une
après-midi en famille puis une soirée
électorale dans son QG de campagne à
rang vous êtes confiante ben écoutez on
a toutes nos chances au vu des résultat
du premier tour avec l'écart entre par
rapport à nos deux adversaires
principaux oui oui oui
le verdict des urnes sera maintenant
connu dans un peu moins d'une
heure et en attendant les premières
estimation je vous rappelle le chiffre
de la participation à 17h en Bourgogne
Franche compté
52,79 % c'est une forte hausse 10 points
de plus par rapport au premier tour
alors voyons quels sont les départements
les plus citoyens en ce deème tour le
tour d'horizon des h départements de
Bourgogne et de frangechecé nous sommes
en direct de la préfecture de Dijon nous
retrouvons Emmanuel son pour ce tour
d'horizon
Emmanuel oui alors par rapport à
dimanche dernier à la même heure on a
plus voté partout à 17h dans tous les
départements un sursaut d'en moyenne 10
points c'est encore une fois comme
dimanche dernier dans Lyonne qu'c le
plus mobilisé jusque-l avec 57,5 % de
participation à 17h 10 points de plus
qu'il y a une semaine
55,7 pour la Côte d'Or qui améliore son
taux de participation de 11 points la 3è
marche du podium pour la haute zone avec
53,3 % contre 43,7 dimanche dernier
viennent ensuite le territoire de
bellefort 52,6 % le Jura
52,4 la sonéoire
51,1 le dou 50,3 %. et puis en queue de
Ploton enfin la Nièvre qui était déjà au
premier tour à 17h le seul département
de la région sous les 40 % de
participation il est aujourd'hui le seul
toujours en dernière position et sous la
barre cette fois des 50 % à
49,3 % de participation et donc toujours
à 17h merci manuel France 3.fr pour
retrouver ces chiffres au et puis un
autre chiffre à présent celui de
l'estimation de la participation
définitive des estimation selon Ipsos
sopra Steria
60,8 % de participation donc ça serait
l'estimation pour la Bourgogne
FrancheComté on est toujours à 10 points
de plus par rapport au premier tour et
c'est légèrement au-dus de l'estimation
pour le national Éric SIO je me tourne
vers vous qu'est-ce qu'on peut déduire
notamment de cette forte hausse de la
participation toute la question en fait
est évidemment de savoir si ce sont les
nombreuxes appelles à faire barrage au
Front National qui ont produit leur
effets alors qu'il est il faut rester
excessivement prudent l'extrême droite
n'avait alors jamais été en mesure de
remporter une région or en Bourgogne
comme en franchecté la participation a
toujours augmenté entre les deux tours
des régionales entre 3 et 5 points de
plus en 2000 2004 près de 7 points de
plus en 2010 en Franche compté et 5
points et demi de plus en Bourgogne un
certain nombre d'électeurs attendent
donc que l'enjeu se soit clarifié à
l'issue du premier tour pour prendre la
peine de se déplacer aux urnes mais
cette année l'ampleur de la différence
entre les deux tours est
particulièrement impressionnante cela
ramène le taux de la participation aux
élections de 2004 alors il semble
évident que la dramatisation de l'enjeu
a joué son rôle tous les partis
politiques présents à ce deuxème tour
sont allés à la pêche aux abstention
pendant les derniers jours de la
campagne des partis de gauche éliminés
comme Europe Écologie Les Verts et le
Parti communiste ont eux aussi mouillé
la chemise pour convaincre les électeurs
d'aller voter ce dimanche on avait
d'ailleurs ressenti ce sursaut dès
vendredi avec un nombre de procurations
parfois doublé comme à Dijon ou à nere
en tout cas d'après les premières
remontées du terrain l'augmentation de
la participation serait plus sensible
dans les villes ce qui est généralement
plus favorable à la gauche mais dans le
même temps tous les départements sont
concernés qu'il soit plus favorable à la
gauche à la droite ou au FN alors pour
l'heure on ne peut dire qu'une seule
chose c'est que la par la participation
citoyenne a été plus forte et cela tout
le monde doit s'en réjouir merci Éric un
tour dehorizon à présent des QG des
trois candidats nous partons pour rend
dans le Jura où le Front national réunit
ses militants devant ce QG nous
retrouvons Maxime
villerilo bonsoir Éric bonsoir ha
bonsoir à tous difficile de vous dire
quelle est l'ambiance ici au que j de
Sophi Montel nous sommes devant la
mairie de Ran un petit village de 530
habitants situés entre Dol et Besançon
la salle de réception de cette mairie
jouracienne a été retenue par la tête de
liste FN Bourgogne franchcé parce que
son maire se réclame du parti de Marine
Le Pen et nous n'avons pas encore été
conviés dans cette salle ne serait-ce
que pour réaliser quelques images je
pense cependant que comme chez les
militants des deux autres candidats euh
donc Marie GUID du faet pour les PS et
ses alliés François sad pour l'IDI et
les les républicains la question qui se
pose est de savoir sur qui se sont
portés les suffrages des
abstentionnistes du premier tour venus
voter en nombre aujourd'hui et une
participation en hausse favorise dit-on
les partis traditionnel et bien ici
comme partout on attend 20h pour avoir
un début de réponse merci Maxime les
partisans de François Sauvadet à présent
pour la liste LR udi seruc à Dijon où
nous retrouvons Théo Soumman y y a-t-il
déjà un petit peu de monde autour de
vous bonsoir Arnaud bonsoir à tous bien
oui les premiers militants viennent
d'arriver ici au QG de campagne dijeunet
de François Sauvadet mais les
sympathisants et les colistiers
arriveront tous un peu avant 20h pour
découvrir ensemble la première
estimation tant attendue ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que François Sauvadet a prévu
d'arriver ici un peu plus tard que
dimanche dernier entre 21h et 21h30 et
comme dimanche dernier il a prévu de
livrer sa première Ré action à ses amis
à son équipe de campagne réunie ici
comme dimanche dernier celui qui conduit
la liste udi LR à ses élections
régionales a voté ce matin à vitau dans
ce petit village de Côte d'Or euh où il
est apparu un peu tendu ce qui peut se
comprendre he tant l'équation électorale
de ce second tour en bourgonne Francé
paraît ce soir incertaine toute la
semaine François Sauvadet a mené
campagne mettant en avant son équipe
resté inchangé au lendemain du premier
tour il n'y a pas eu de fusion
mettant aussi en avant sa deuxème place
récoltée au premier tour lui permettant
disait-il de rassembler autour de sa
candidature et pas d'une autre il a fait
également deux grands meetings en
franchecté à montbellliard puis à vezou
la franchecté où il a totalisé un nombre
de votes inférieur à la Bourgogne reste
à savoir si tous ces efforts ont payés
s'ils ont suffi à le propulser en tête
au second tour
la réponse évidemment tout à l'heure
merci Théo le programme de de la soirée
maintenant pour la liste PS de mariegit
Duffet nous sommes pour cela en direct
du cursal de Besançon où la gauche se
donne rendez-vous bonsoir Thierry
Chaufour bonsoir ambiance encore assez
froide ici au cursal à Besançon une
trentaine de personnes tout au plus sont
déjà arrivé c'est mieux que la semaine
dernière dimanche dernier à la même
heure cette grande salle du centreville
de bon était totalement déserte les
militants étaient restés chez eux AB
basourdi par le score du Front national
et par la 3è place seulement de la
candidate socialiste Marie guit Duffet
ce soir les militants pensent que Marie
guit Duffet peut l'emporter il faut dire
qu'un accord a très vite été trouvé
entre la candidate socialiste les
écologistes et le Front de gauche et
mamatiquement effectivement Marie GUID
Duffet peut l'emporter ce soir si le
report de voie est bon on sait que la
participation elle est largement
supérieure à ce qu'elle était dimanche
dernier voilà les militants arrivent
petit à petit on attend également ici
les responsables politiques et les élus
de Bezançon Jean-Louis Fousseret le
maire de bzançon devrait arriver ici
vers 20h15 on attend également Éric
alosé député Europe Écologie du dou on
vous fera parti on vous fera profiter
pardon de leur première réaction un
petit peu plus tard dans la soirée merci
à tout à l'heure nous serons également
en direct de ou encore doser dans le
courant de cette soirée spéciale sur
France 3 Jérémy chevreuil on l'entend
dans chaque quand il y a des espoirs
légitimes c'est vraiment en Bourgogne
franchecé une soirée à suspense ah ben
oui a parce que la leçon en quelque
sorte de la semaine dernière c'est que
les trois finalistes peuvent l'emporter
ce soir d'abord Sophie Montel arrivé
largement en tête au premier tour elle
peut bonifier son score de la semaine
passée grâce notamment aux électeurs
souverainistes de Debout la France ou de
l'uppr par exemple car contrairement à
certaines idées reçus le FN n'a pas
atteint son plafond de verre la semaine
dernière le FN a aussi des réserves chez
les abstentionnistes la Bourgogne
franchecté pourrait être ce soir l'une
des régions ou peut-être même la seule
région FN de France à gauche la
socialiste Marie guide Duffet compteelle
sur la mobilisation de ce qu'on appelle
le peuple de gauche les communistes et
les écologistes ont appelé à voter pour
elle la seule femme présidente sortante
de région pourrait donc le rester
symboliquement la Bourgogne franchecté
serait alors la région sauvée entre
guillemets du FN par une union de la
gauche qui n'existerait que dans les
urnes à défaut d'exister politiquement
au gouvernement et puis François sauvadé
la droite avait la gueule de bois
dimanche dernier déçue par son score un
point seulement d'avance sur le PS
malgré la division de la gauche alors
François Sauvadet a fait ses comptes et
au souent nous disait tout à l'heure il
manque des voix en franchecté du coup
François sauvad a battu la campagne en
haut zone dans le Jura et dans le dou
cette semaine si ça paye il peut
l'emporter sur le fil ce soir et à
droite on saluerait alors le succès de
cette union entre l'UDI et les
républicains une chose est sûre quel que
soit le résultat la bourg franche compté
aura des allures de cerises pour le
gâteau sur le gâteau pour le parti qui
l'emportera ce soir à l'heure du bilan
de ces régional merci beaucoup Jérémy en
tout cas restez bien avec nous pour
suivre cette soirée on l'a dit encore
très indécise pour les résultats tout au
long de cette soirée nous allons
régulièrement aller du côté du studio de
Besançon où nous attend Catherine mziri
Catherine bonsoir quels seront vos
invités tout à
l'heure et bien oui nous aurons de
nombreux invités ce soir sur le plate
ici à Besançon par exemple Barbara
Romagnan la députée socialiste du dou
elle fait partie de ce qu'on appelle le
groupe des frondeurs à l'Assemblée
nationale nous attendons également
Michel Zumkeller député maire de Valdois
dans le Territoire de Belfort c'est le
numéro 3 de l'UDI et puis nous attendons
avec beaucoup d'impatience Sophie Montel
la candidate du Front national en effet
va rester sur
Besançon au cours de cette soirée à ce
moment-là nous saurons aux alentours de
22h15 si ce Sophie Montel a réussi à
gagner ça cette cette région et celle a
réussi à en être présidente merci
Catherine la campagne d'entre de Tours
c'est animé notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux là où les premiers commentaires
arrivent en attendant les résultats es a
Besin les candidats éliminés dimanche
dernier sont restés dans la course via
Twitter oui à l'image vous allez le voir
du tweet de Maxime thébo candidat debout
la France un message posté cet
après-midi impatient de savoir le
résultat de ce soir dans tous les cas il
sera riche d'enseignement autre message
vous le voyez de Carole Bernard une
candidate d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
qui semble craindre une victoire du
Front national a voté et maintenant a
envie de vomir j'ai mal à ma
représentation démocratique autre
message c'est une photo de l'influent
David Lano du Gret qui semble c'est un
ancien candidat des municipales à Dijon
et qui attend les résultats vous le
voyez avec une boîte de dolipran au cas
où alors au cas où quoi on ne sait pas
plus pragmatique ce message de notre
confrère fr Christophe Taris qui écrit
j'ai pris des cours
d'origami histoire de mieux plier ses
bulletins bien trop grands et puis je
vais terminer avec deux tweets ce tweet
de ma consœur Armel gagron de Lyonne
républicaine qui écrit un électeur du
bureau 1 Avallon a laissé ses photos
d'identité dans l'enveloppe à la place
du bulletin et puis ce dernier tweet
c'est aussi une conur d'Europe 1
reporter d'Europe 1 armée Aurélie
Herbemont qui écrit vous le voyez quand
en ce moment même Nicolas Sarkozi réunit
ses principaux lieutenant dans son
bureau parisien et parmi ceuxci il y a
Alain Joyandet chef de fil régional pour
les républicains merci beaucoup Elsa les
rédactions internet bien évidemment sont
sur le pont ce soir on retrouve notre
pilote web Sophie courageo Sophie
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir lire sur les
sites internet ce soir
oui bonsoir bien écoutez depuis 18h
Notre fil info minute par minute est
ouvert vous on vous accompagne toutes la
soirée avec le meilleur des tweets les
photos d'ambiance les réactions les
reportages de nos équipes sur le terrain
et puis surtout sur nos sites vous
trouverez les résultats en temps réel
dès qu'ils nous seront communiqués par
le ministère de l'intérieur vous pourrez
même chercher comment on a voté dans
votre commune qu'elle soit petite ou
grande comment on a voté dans votre
département la soirée vous l'avez dit
promet du suspense une seule adresse
France 3.fr merci beaucoup Sophie
rendez-vous sur la et puis bien
évidemment et bien sur France 3 Arna oui
tout de suiteédition nationale du 1920
nous nous retrouvons dès 20h15 pour la
toute première estimation en Bourgogne
et en Fran compé d'ici là également
france3.fr à tout à l'heure la soirée ne
fait que
commencer